six seeded rams at the top seed green
bay packers
here is aaron donald the great rams
defensive tackle on facing the other
great aaron in the game quarterback
aaron rodgers
a big quarterback is playing lights out
this year making some great throws
making some good decisions obviously um
he can do things with his feet you know
not the fastest guy but he can move
um he can get away from you make things
happen you know so we got to do a great
job as far as
um bottom up getting pressure on him you
know not making them making a
you know having letting him have a clean
pocket to the point where you know he
can make all them great throws so
um you know we got a challenge you know
but you know that's what you expect in
the playoff
game aaron donald is carved out of
granite i mean i see him talking i want
to go run and hide my god
how does anybody block him
hey you know in talking to uh
in talking to the defensive coordinator
brandon staley for my podcast this week
told me a great aaron donald story
he he he said that at tampa he called
the defense that had aaron donald
basically playing contain
you know and making sure that you know
brady didn't do x on a specific uh pass
drop and so
at the end of that play brady converted
it into a first down and at the end of
that series donald went to the sidelines
puts his arm around brandon staley and
he says hey let me play
just let me play you know and staley
goes okay okay so i think
one of the reasons that and this is what
i've heard independent of talking to
staley one of the reasons these players
like
brandon staley
is that he is
a he runs a
you know he doesn't run on autocratic
defense
he takes suggestions and not just from
the coaches from the players when he got
there he told jalen ramsey essentially
hey listen
i i want to play you all over the map i
don't want you locking on to dk metcalf
or the best receiver every week i want
to do different things with you and he
said coach i've been waiting a long time
to play in the slot i've always wanted
to do that so
i think by staley saying to these guys
look we're going to try to play you to
your strengths
and we want to know what you want to do
what you like to do
i think that has gotten both donald
ramsey and all these kind of rising
stars young stars particularly in that
secondary to really like this scheme
and i think you know just look at this i
mean it's
it's incredible how good the rams
defense
has been in a year keep this in mind
keep this in mind mike it's a year
when there's no off-season program to
get used to and to come into a new
defense and make no mistake
big big changes in this defense because
brandon staley runs a defense a lot like
vic fangios that's where he was before
and fangios is like a unique defense
you know it changes really a lot week to
week so these players on that defense
have to be malleable and have to be
willing to change every week and they
are and that's one of the reasons why
those numbers are so good
and it's funny i think back to last year
when wade phillips was sort of
unceremoniously forced out of la and the
reaction was what are you what are you
doing you're taking a step back
defensively you're moving on from wade
phillips what do you think and what
they're thinking is we're going to get a
guy who's going to take the defense in a
different direction and and take it
frankly to a higher level than it had
been and the shift in this franchise in
the last two years is stunning it's gone
from this offensive high wire
reincarnation of the greatest show-offs
on turf and now it's this this defense
and the question is the offense good
enough
to to help
the defense get to where it needs to be
and i guess that's the question i'll
pose to you now peter we know the
defense is great we know jaylen ramsey
is going to be all over devante adams
and i think it's going to fall to aaron
jones to try to make something happen in
in what is an audition for him for other
teams is he becomes a free agent if the
packers don't keep him but can the rams
offense do enough against the packers
defense for it for it all to make any
any difference when it comes to whether
or not the rams can pull off the upset
that's the big question you know can
golf make enough plays you know i talked
to goff last week after uh that huge win
in seattle and he emphasized to me about
seven times
i am not in pain
my thumb
is good enough to play it's not perfect
and yes when i make some throws i notice
it but i'm not in pain don't make
anything there's no excuses for me if i
don't play well enough and i thought
that was good because
it's easy for a guy to say ah my thumb's
fine mike i can tell you he came back to
it literally three times
you know he kept saying this and he said
when you write something don't write
that you know how how bad this is it's
not a big obstacle for me those stats on
that board right there to me
and as conservative as sean mcvay played
he wanted his defense to win that game
last week because he knew that goff
wasn't 100
and he knew that he hadn't really been
playing very well up to that point
and i think you're going to see a
similar kind of game
they're going to try to play a 20 to 14
game either way
and they're just hoping that their
running game and a limited passing game
can complement
what i think will be a really tough
defense for green bay to play against
remember that sunday night game the rams
played in chicago a couple of years ago
and it was cold but i mean it wasn't ice
bowl conditions
and jared goff looked like he wanted to
go crawl under a rock somewhere right
with a big thermos a hot chocolate i and
it's going to be 32 degrees right around
kickoff tomorrow when they play so this
is going to be a test and this is an
opportunity for jared goff
to prove
that that he can thrive under these
kinds of conditions there are some in
the media i'm told who will derisively
refer to jared goff as jared country
club goff this is his chance this is his
opportunity and there's some tension
there peter between mcveigh and goff
right now i don't know how closely
you've been there
yeah but there's definitely tension
they're still cleaning up the mess from
last week over john wolford starting
when jared goff was adamant as he told
you
i'm not in pain my thumb is fine
sims believes that there's a fascination
by mcveigh with john walford because
mcveigh may think walford can run the
offense a little bit better than goff
does and i keep coming back to why'd
they give the guy 33 and a half million
a year in new money if that's the case
but this is something that
that that could build
in la and all of a sudden the chargers
have the far better quarterback than
justin herbert and you can't help but
wonder whether or not sean mcvay is
doing what his mentor john gruden would
do which is have the wandering eye for a
better quarterback and maybe he's found
one in his own building
uh you never know i don't think he's
seen enough of wolford to really know
that
and you know you'd have liked wolford to
play a little bit better against arizona
really
he was okay but was he
he wasn't jalen hurts in his first two
games let's just say that and so i i
kind of look at this and say i got my
eye on this i think it's interesting and
there's no question
that look you you could all you have to
do is look at the numbers look at the
stats
at how goff played you know in the last
six to eight weeks and
and and you know the the inconsistency
and it doesn't there's you don't even
have to have an inside source
you can just tell
that sean mcvay
is not happy with the way his offense
played in the last half of the season
and if it continues he's probably not
going to stand for it what does that
mean i don't know
but you can be sure it's like mike
remember when the carson wentz thing
happened and everybody was talking about
how
oh boy carson wentz is ticked off he's
this and bucky brick bucky brooks of uh
of nfl.com came out and he basically
said you know
uh carson wentz basically has got to
settle down when you're named starting
quarterback it is not a lifetime
appointment
you got to perform and it'll be the same
thing with golf if this continues i
think into next season
yeah and i've looked at that contract
before and
uh they're they're joined at the hip for
a couple more years unless they find a
trade partner and unlike the eagles who
have a chance to find a trade partner in
the colts
i don't think anybody all due respect is
trading for jared goff and that contract
because i think most people look at that
contract and they look at the player and
they say
what what the hell were the rams
thinking all right let's see the only
way you do it mike is if the only way
you do it is if the cap goes way way up
and all of a sudden that contract
doesn't seem so horrible and 15
quarterbacks pass them in the next year
but otherwise i totally agree with you
yeah
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports